We're talking about...
Ja, FIFA und das Thema Doping, das soll uns auch rund im Kontext dieser Weltmeisterschaft 2018 in Russland beschäftigen und damit hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Hacob-Oss, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und Moderator dieser kleinen Sendung, in der wir mal so alle Aspekte ein bisschen aufarbeiten wollen, die rund um Doping mit der WM interessant sind und dann eben auch einige Fragen stellen, nämlich kann man davon ausgehen, dass eventuell doch gedoppt wird oder sind das alles nur Mutmaßungen. Dazu habe ich zwei sehr, sehr, sehr kompetente Menschen hier bei mir versammelt in der Runde und ich bin sehr froh, dass ich Grit Hartmann hier begrüßen darf. Sie recherchiert im Bereich des IOC schon länger, auch über Doping und im Grunde eigentlich über so fast alle Themen, die die großen Sportverbände gerne unter dem Teppich lassen würden, unter denen sie sie selbst gekehrt haben. Sie heißt atgrit-hartmann bei Twitter, hat skandalöserweise noch keinen eigenen Wikipedia-Eintrag, aber sie ist hier im Rasenfunk. Hallo Grit, schön, dass du mal mit dabei bist. Und außerdem schon eine bekannte Stimme aus schon einigen Sendungen zum Thema Fußball-Doping. Jonathan Sachse vom Correctiv, dem investigativen Recherchenetzwerk. Er schreibt unter anderem auf Fußball-Doping.de seit Jahren konsequent über das Thema und war auch schon mehrfach hier im Rasenfunk. Servus Jonathan. Freut mich sehr, dass wir diese illustre Runde haben. Bevor wir loslegen, danke ich noch ganz herzlich. Stefan.exe, Nina, Maximilian, Emanuel, Gustav und Ed Manuon, sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporter. Das heißt, sie unterstützen, dass der Rasenfunk weiter werbefrei und sponsorenfrei bleiben kann. Und in dem Sinne seid auch ihr Unterstützer, denn ihr bekommt leider noch kein Herr Honorar für eure Zeit hier und habt euch trotzdem auf diese Sendung vorbereitet. Deswegen vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank schon mal für eure Teilnahme. Wer uns unterstützen möchte, kann das tun auf rasenfunk.de/.unterstützen. Aber jetzt wollen wir mal zum Thema kommen. Grit, warum lohnt sich denn im Bereich Fußball und Doping ein Blick auf den Fußball besonders?
Na ja, ganz klar. Also wir wollen jetzt mal nicht, da sind wir uns, glaube ich, in der Runde einig über diese Fantasie-Aussagen reden, dass Fußball im Doping nichts bringt.
Wer das noch glaubte, soll das Tribünengespräch mit Jonathan hören. Da haben wir das in vier Stunden auseinandergenommen.
Das sind Interessenten, die so was behaupten, aber eben auch angeblich Fachkundige, was schon mal eine Menge sagt über Doping und Fußball. Wenn eine Art Nationalmannschaft der Deutschen so was behauptet, dann sieht man, dass es da offensichtlich auch was zu verbergen gibt. Das wäre zumindest meine Schlussfolgerung. Also, warum sich's lohnt? Ganz einfach. Der moderne Fußball ist eine extrem dynamische Sportart. Du brauchst Ausdauer, du brauchst Kraftausdauer, du brauchst Schnellkraft für Sprints und vor allen Dingen brauchst du die Fähigkeit, dich schnell erholen zu können. Weil die Belastung gerade im Spitzenfußball ist enorm. Es gab mal Hebungen, woraus kam, dass so 40 Spiele in der Saison gut wären und gerade noch so verträglich es sind, aber in der Regel über 60. Also Fußballer haben eine extrem hohe Belastung, auch durch einen übervollen Spielekalender. Das ist schon mal der eine Punkt. Der zweite ist, wir haben viele Fälle Fußball-Doping, die meisten durch Staatsanwaltschaften rausgekommen, also oder durch wissenschaftliche Untersuchungen. Deutschland in den 50er, 60er, 70er Jahren, 80er, das hat der Blick auf die Freiburger Doping-Gepflogenheiten ergeben, haben wir zum Beispiel umfangreiche Anabolika-Programme beim VfB Stuttgart gehabt. Wir haben internationale Fälle, also Juventus, Turin in den 90er Jahren, systematisches Doping. Wir haben die Anhaltspunkte in Spanien mit dem berühmten Gynäkologen Oefimiano Fuentes, der also da gesagt hat, seine Kunden seien überhaupt nicht in der Mehrzahl Radsportler gewesen, sondern Fußballer. Die Aussage hat er dann zurückgezogen. Sie ist auch nie genauer untersucht worden, aber er hat angeblich Fußballer aus vier Clubs behandelt. Und die offizielle Statistik gibt nicht viel her, aber die sagt immerhin, dass es im letzten Jahr international 76 Dopingfälle gab. Das ist aber die Spitze des Eisbergs. Und der allerletzte, der letzte Punkt, wir haben äußerst interessante Studien. Da hat zum Beispiel ein ehemaliger Profifußballer vor zwei Jahren in Deutschland auch seine Ex-Kollegen befragt. Die waren ein bisschen auskunftsfreudiger, als sie das vielleicht sonst sind, einfach weil es ein ehemaliger Profifußballer war. Und da haben für die Bundesliga bis zu 25 Prozent der Spieler eingeräumt. Sie hätten schon mal gedoppt. Und das ist angesichts der Dopingfälle, die man offiziell hat, eine extreme Dunkelziffer. In Spanien waren es sogar 30 Prozent, die es zugegeben haben. Und das sind so ein paar Punkte, die mir auf die Schnelle einfallen, warum man sich das schon genau angucken sollte. Über Russland habe ich jetzt noch gar nicht geredet und was da offengelegt worden ist.
Ich glaube, da kommen wir heute auch noch hin. Jetzt ist es aber so, Jonathan, im Vergleich zu anderen Sportarten. Ich habe heute noch auf dem Weg in den Kindergarten – also nicht ich bin in den Kindergarten gegangen, sondern Angehörige meiner Familie – habe ich dann noch auf dem Rückweg in einem Podcast eine ausführliche Diskussion über Froome und die jetzt bald startende Tour de France gehört und habe mir wieder gedacht, wie unterschiedlich Doping-Diskussionen je nach Sportarten geführt werden. Kannst du dir erklären, warum es im Fußball eher ein Nebenthema ist, ein kaum auftauchendes Thema in der aktuellen Berichterstattung?
Ja, also in Ansätzen zumindestens. Ich glaube, du hast jetzt im Vergleich zum Radsport angestellt. Der Radsport hat ja auch sehr unterschiedliche Phasen gehabt. Dort wurde das ja auch mal anders thematisiert. Das muss man glaube ich immer im Hintergrund haben. Das ging ja sozusagen seit 2006 erst los, dass sich der Radsport da zumindest in der Berichterstattung der Fokus auch Richtung Doping verlagert hat. Und ich glaube, dieser Schritt ist einfach noch nicht passiert im Fußball. Da könnten wir jetzt länger über die Gründe reden. Ich glaube, ein wesentlicher Grund ist, dass uns da noch sozusagen in der Gegenwart jetzt, außer das russische System, sozusagen die ganz großen aktuellen Erkenntnisse fehlen, sodass es sozusagen zwangsweise zum Thema wird. Also wenn man mal überlegt, wie gelangt man überhaupt zu solchen Erkenntnissen, dann sind das – Grit hat schon mehrere Instanzen angesprochen – also Wissenschaftler, die, sagen wir mal, Epochen später dann sozusagen erforschen, was da los war. Vielleicht ein bisschen aktueller, die anonyme Befragung, die Grit angesprochen hat, sonst Antidopingbehörden oder Staatsanwaltschaften, die allerdings mit begrenzten Mitteln arbeiten. Dann bleiben am Ende nur die Journalisten, die an mehreren Stellen deutlich schwieriger einen tiefen Einblick bekommen und dann darauf angewiesen sind, dass sie erstmal ein bisschen Zeit investieren und darauf angewiesen sind, dass sie Menschen finden, zu denen sie Vertrauen aufbauen können und die dann wirklich über Erfahrungen sprechen oder teilen, was sie irgendwo beobachtet haben. Und das können ja ehemalige Sportler sein, Mitarbeiter in irgendwelchen Verbänden oder Laboren und dann im besten Fall einen sogar Dokumente liefern, wo dann wirklich Fakten draufstehen, um der Wahrheit ein bisschen näher zu kommen. Und ich glaube, dieser ganze Prozess, der ist einfach noch nicht so weit, wie er sein könnte im Fußball.
Ist denn der Fußball da vielleicht verschwiegener Grit als andere Sportarten?
Er ist auf alle Fälle weniger unabhängig. Also das beste Beispiel haben wir jetzt bei der Fußball-WM und das zieht sich aber auch zum Beispiel bis zur deutschen NADA. Du hast Kontrolleure von der FIFA und es gibt anders als bei Olympischen Spielen allen anderen Weltmeisterschaften, in anderen Sportarten, Leichtathletik, was auch immer. Es gibt keinen Zutritt für unabhängige Beobachter. Selbst die WADA hat keinen Zutritt. Das heißt, das wird alles im geschlossenen Kreis abgewickelt, weil ich sagte, das zieht sich bis nach Deutschland. Für die Doping-Kontrollen im deutschen Fußball, die schon quantitativ völlig unzureichend sind, hast du Extrakontrolleure. Das sind ehemalige, auch unter Regie der Nada, aber Extrakontrolleure, die nur den Fußball kontrollieren. Du hast besondere Meldevorgaben. Das hat jetzt der Bayerische Rundfunk, das war es, glaube ich, mal recherchiert. Während es sonst laut WADA-Code, Weltantidopingagentur-Code vorgeschrieben ist, dass erst der Sportler informiert wird über einen positiven Dopingfall, wird hier der Club informiert, also der Bundesliga-Verein. Es gibt in Antidoping eigentlich zwei Welten. Es gibt den Olympischen Sport und es gibt den Fußball. Ein Aspekt, das ich für extrem wichtig halte, das ist das Geld im Fußball. Das ist schlicht und einfach wirklich eine Milliardenbranche. Und was Jonathan angesprochen hat, ist nicht nur so, dass der Zugang im Fußball sehr schwer ist. Die Fußballer und Vereine, Agenten, wer da alles mitmüscht, sind auch extrem geschützt. Selbstverständlich leisten die sich die teuersten Anwälte. Es gab gerade so einen Fall, ich will jetzt nicht genau sagen, wen es betrifft, aber da hat ein Fußballer in England geklagt, gegen ein deutsches Medium. Dort ist das Presserecht sehr locker. Dort kommst du also mit Klagen und Schadensersatzforderungen durch, die du in Deutschland nie durchkriegen würdest, weil du alle journalistischen Standards eingehalten hast. Das Geld spielt übrigens auch bei dem geschlossenen Handling der Doping-Tests eine große Rolle. Man stelle sich doch mal vor, was passiert, wir reden jetzt zum Beispiel bei Ronaldo über Transfersummen im dreistelligen Millionen-Euro-Bereich, wenn der überführt würde und für vier Jahre gesperrt würde oder auch nur zwei Jahre, was das wirtschaftlich bedeutet. Also die FIFA, auch das kann man noch dazu sagen. Ich meine, das ist einer der korruptesten Weltverbände, die es überhaupt gibt. Ermittlungen in über 30 Ländern gegen Funktionäre. Ich glaube im Moment, warum soll man darauf vertrauen, dass die ausgerechnet die Doping-Tests ehrlich oder transparent haben? Ja, also da hängt richtig viel dran und die Zugangsmöglichkeiten im Fußball sind, weil es da um massive Wirtschaftsfaktoren geht, für die Recherche sehr viel schwerer als anderswo.
Vielleicht können wir das an einem Fall nochmal ganz kurz erläutern, den viele ja verfolgt haben. Das war der Fall Paolo Guerrero vor der WM, wo so ein Teilen, das was Grit Hartmann beschrieben hat, ja auch schon deutlich wurde, was passiert, wenn es dann mal einen positiv ausgesprochenen Test gibt. Über den Test an sich wurde ja viel diskutiert, ob was da die Gründe sind. Aber das passiert ja bei jedem Doping-Fall, dass erst mal Gründe gefunden werden, warum das jetzt kein echter Doping-Fall war. Und was damals ja passiert ist, so dieser kuriose Weg, den ich – ich habe da gar keinen Vergleich, aber Grit hat da oft einen besseren Überblick, ob es das schon mal gab, dass sozusagen eine Sperre ausgesprochen wurde, beziehungsweise jetzt nach Einspruch noch verhandelt wurde. Und dann hat ein Schweizer Bundesgericht diese Sperre sozusagen on hold gesetzt, mit dieser absurden Begründung. Das ist ungefähr das 1 zu 1 Zitat, dass ja jetzt die Krönung seiner Fußballkarriere ansteht, die soll nicht gefährdet werden. So steht es im Schreiben von dem Gericht. Und deswegen durfte Gero jetzt für Periwou antreten. Und danach beendet er ja vielleicht seine Karriere. Also ob was dann genau mit der Sperre danach passiert, das muss man mal abwarten, aber die ist dann vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr relevant. Und ich finde, da konnte man in kleinen Schritten immer sehen, was so möglich ist bei Fußballern, wie viel Einfluss da im Spiel ist, wenn dann mal was ausgesprochen wird. Und das ist ja noch nicht der allergrößte, prominenteste Name. Aber in dem Land, Peru, natürlich irgendwie einer der ganz großen Akteure, was da sozusagen alles auch politisch unternommen wurde, damit er am Ende spielen kann, das fand ich schon sehr spannend, von hier ganz weit weg zu beobachten.
Bis dahin, dass der Präsident sich in der Fernsehansprache ans Fröck gewandt hat und seine Solidarität ausgedrückt hat. Aber ich bin bei dem Fall, also mir fällt jetzt auf Anhieb kein Vergleichbarer ein. Ich weiß nur, dass Claudia Pechstein seinerzeit immer beim Schweizer Bundesgericht Aufhebung von Spermen für Olympische Spiele beantragt hat und dass daraus nichts geworden ist. Aber hier bin ich ein kleines bisschen zurückhaltender, ehrlich gesagt, auch wenn es ein bisschen absurd klingt. Also da gab es erst eine Sperre von sechs Monaten durch die FIFA, dann hat der CAS, also der Weltsportgerichtshof, auf 14 Monate verlängert und das ist die Sperre, die jetzt ausgesetzt worden ist durchs Schweizer Bundesgericht. Aber hier hat der CAS, also der Weltsportgerichtshof, in einer Pressemitteilung geschrieben, das ist CAS-Urteil, da liegt noch keine ausführliche Begründung vor, aber die Pressemitteilung sagt, dass er nicht vorsätzlich oder grob fahrlässig gehandelt hat und auch keine Leistung damit steigern wollte. Der hatte also Kokain-Restbestandteile beim Doping-Test, die also in Peru in irgendeinem Coca-Tee – ich war da noch nicht, da kenne ich mich nicht aus damit – wohl vorkommen. Und man hat ihm abgenommen, auch der Weltsportgerichtshof, dass es so zu diesem positiven Test gekommen ist. Es gab, und das kann man jetzt so oder so deuten, auch ein Appell der Internationalen Spielervereinigung, FIFPO, die um Aufhebung dieser Sperre gebeten haben. Die anderen nationalen Mannschaftskapitäne aus der Vorrundengruppe Frankreich, Australien, Dänemark waren das. Die haben also auch in Richtung Aufhebung plädiert. Auch der WADA-Code sieht ja vor, dass man bei solchen Fällen nicht die Mindestsperre, die eigentlich gilt von zwei Jahren, geben muss. Es ist nicht so ein ganz einfacher Fall. Natürlich gibt es die Ausrede immer, aber hier hat auch der Weltsportgerichtshof entschieden, okay, das war keine Absicht. Und er hat seine Leistung nicht steigern wollen und auch nicht können damit.
Stimme ich dazu, Gritte, nur eine Nachfrage, da würde mich deine Bewertung interessieren. Sorry, Max, dass ich jetzt ganz kurz moderat und viel, aber der Schaffer hat gerade nur eine Frage. Und zwar, ich finde es einfach nur interessant, unabhängig von der Bewertung, ist eigentlich ein Fall, wie viel Bewegung gesetzt wird, auch von den anderen Nationen, dass er tatsächlich dann spielberechtigt ist. Vielleicht fragen wir euch beide, seht ihr das so, dass es ein großes Ungerechtigkeitsempfinden ist, die die anderen Nationen auch mittragen? Oder ist es dann doch eher so die Macht des Fußballs, die einfach für eine außergewöhnliche Gegenwehr dazu in der Lage ist, auch so viele Verbände mit einzubeziehen, dass man insgesamt einfach noch mehr Power hat, wenn man versucht, etwas gegen einen positiven Test zu unternehmen?
Soll ich meine brutale Antwort geben? Vielleicht wissen die alle, womit wirklich gedopft wird und finden deshalb so ein QKT lächerlich. Das könnte eine Erklärung sein. Das ist jetzt eine sehr kühne Erklärung, aber das kann ich nicht wirklich beantworten, die Frage.
Ja, klar.
Ich meine, Sepp Latte würde jetzt natürlich sagen, das ist einfach die Fußballfamilie, die hält zusammen. Da würden dann allerdings so manche US-Behörden sagen, ja, so eine Fußballfamilie sieht manchmal dann aber auch wie eine mafiöse Struktur aus, die man nach gewissen Mafia-Gesetzen auch verklagen kann. Also so ganz wissen wir es nicht. Aber es ist schon interessant, auch wie mit diesem Fall umgegangen wird in der Öffentlichkeit. Also natürlich haben sich einige drüber lustig gemacht. Die eigentlich drüberstehende Frage, die ich jetzt auch mit Bezug auf die WM interessant finde, ist für mich eigentlich, wie bewertet ihr beide denn dieses Gerichtsbarkeitsprinzip, das wir da haben, also das wir da Sportgerichte haben, aber jetzt habt ihr ja auch immer wieder vom Schweizer Bundesgericht auch gesprochen. Kann denn der Sport über sich selbst eigentlich urteilen in Fällen des Doppings? Ist dem Sport diese Kompetenz zuzutrauen? Grit, was würdest du sagen?
Und zwar extrem durch, du hast es vorhin angesprochen, durch das Frohm-Urteil. Das hat alle Grundsätze, die man da bisher so kannte, umgekippt. Es gibt bis heute keine wirkliche Begründung dafür, warum. Also noch mal für die Hörer, der hatte Salbutamol, das ist ein Asthmamittel, Intus und zwar die doppelte Menge des Erlaubten. Das ist erlaubt, wenn du eine medizinische Ausnahmegenehmigung hast, und die hat er auf Frohm, aber nicht die doppelte Menge. So und er ist dennoch freigesprochen worden. Da gab es also teure Anwälte, die er beschäftigt hat. Eine Studie an Hunden, die gezeigt hat, dass man auch mit der normalen Menge diesen Wert erreichen kann, den er hat. Es sind aber Radsportler konkret, Petacchi zum Beispiel, oder Petacchi, weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie er sich spricht, verurteilt worden mit geringeren Werten. Und die war damit einverstanden, die Weltantidoping-Agentur. Und das ist so ein Fall, der wirklich darauf hindeutet, sehr stark, wenn du genug Geld hast, wenn du berühmt genug bist, wenn du dir die Anwälte und die Studien leisten kannst, dann musst du nicht mal mehr sonderlich raffiniert dopen, um einen Freispruch zu erhalten. Also es ist schwierig, es gibt Zweifel, aber ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut an die Zeit Ende der 90er Jahre, als wir alle froh waren, dass DIVADA gegründet wurde und die nationalen Antidoping-Agenturen. DIVADA ist nicht unabhängig. Das ist klar, das internationale Olympische Komitee, der Schwert hat viel zu viel Mitspracherecht im entsprechenden Foundation-Wort und im Aufsichtsrat dort. Aber man war froh, dass es das gab. Und selbstverständlich gibt es auch Erfolge. Aber die größten Fälle, nehmen wir Lenz Armstrong, oder nehmen wir auch Fälle in Spanien oder Italien, das waren eben nicht die Doping-Kontrollen des Sports, sondern das waren Staatsanwaltschaften. Ich würde aber niemals sagen, schafft sie ab oder sowas im Sport, sondern macht sie so unabhängig, wie es geht. Und es muss diese zwei Schienen geben. Also wenn eine Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt, schon weil sie andere Kompetenzen hat, kommt immer mehr raus, als wenn es nur der Sport tut. Und die Anti-Doping-Gesetze in vielen Ländern geben zumindest die Möglichkeit, wie in Deutschland, dass nach einem positiven Test die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt. Es kann nur parallel sein, aber in der Regel muss man den Kontrollen des Sports nicht allzu viel zutrauen und den im Fußball am allerwenigsten.
Ich stimme Grit zu. Ich finde auch, dass es beides geben muss. Und für mich ist der große Lerneffekt aus diesen ganzen Verfahren wie bei Flumin, dass man dann einen Doping-Fall, der in der Vergangenheit bei anderen Akteuren im Sport klar war, dann nicht mehr erreicht, wenn das Geld da ist. Wenn man die großen Namen zu einer Sperre bringen möchte, dann braucht es immer noch ein bisschen mehr, außer einen positiven Test. Dann müssen, wie es bei Armstrong damals war, entweder gearbeitet werden wie ein Staatsanwalt, also dann auch wirklich Zeugenaussagen und alles Mögliche mitbesorgt werden. Oder beide Seiten müssen sozusagen zusammenarbeiten, Antidopingbehörden und staatliche Ermittler.
Darf ich noch was kurz sagen? Ich habe, glaube ich, einen Fehler gemacht. Ich meinte Balko. Balko war ja einer der größten Affären in den USA. Das war eine Steuerbehörde, die das aufgedeckt hat. Der Pfalz Ruhm hat aber noch etwas gezeigt. Den Aspekt muss man, glaube ich, unbedingt erwähnen. Er hat ja in Frage gestellt, die Zuverlässigkeit des WADA-Tests. Wir haben einen sehr, sehr guten Sportmediziner, der sich nun leider aus Antidoping verabschiedet hat. Das ist Prof. Mit dem habe ich sehr oft über die Zuverlässigkeit von Tests gesprochen. Antidoping-Tests. Er ist da einer der großen Skeptiker und sagt, die WADA-Wissenschaft ist bei vielen Tests wackelig. Bei Salbutamol-Freiform ist es gerade, wenn man es positiv auslegt, nachgewiesen worden, dass sie nicht bereit sind, ihren eigenen Test zu verteidigen. Sonst hätten sie diesen Freispruch nicht mitgemacht. Das führt uns natürlich zum Geld, wenn wir gucken, wie Antidoping und Antidoping-Forschung ausgestattet ist. Das sind Bruchteile dessen, was gebraucht würde. Es ist aber nun seit einem Jahrzehnt so, dass die WADA nicht deutlich mehr Geld bekommt. Es gibt da auch ein wissenschaftliches Problem, glaube ich. Aber das ist jetzt wirklich was für Mediziner und Experten. Aber die Ernstzunehmenden sagen, viele WADA-Tests, wenn sie ernsthaft beklagt werden oder auch Blut passt, zum Beispiel, die könnten ein bisschen mehr Wissenschaft vertragen und auch Wissenschaft von außen, nicht die kleine In-Group der Antidoping-Wissenschaftler.
Und habe ich das jetzt vorhin richtig verstanden, Grit, dass aber, wenn wir jetzt über die WADA sprechen und wir jetzt über die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Russland sprechen wollen, dass du dann ja vorhin gesagt hast, die Kontrolleure der FIFA kommen aber nicht aus diesem System, sondern das ist ein eigener Kosmos.
Genau, absolut. Also die WADA hat da keinen Zutritt, gar nichts.
Wie kann denn das eigentlich sein? Wie kommt denn das? Ist ja eigentlich total absurd.
Ja, es ist total absurd. Es ist total absurd, wie viel ist im Fußball. Also das kann man nicht wirklich erklären. Die WADA hat nun mitgeteilt, sie hat mal den einen Zahn gezeigt, den sie hat, aber darüber lacht man eigentlich auch und hat gesagt, es gibt nach der Weltmeisterschaft ein intensives Gespräch mit der FIFA. Genau so, da kann man eigentlich nur drüber lachen. Die WADA hat keinen Zutritt, das war schon unter Blatter so und ist unter Infantin und nicht anders.
Aber zur Einordnung, man muss sehen, das ist insgesamt ein Fußballproblem. Also, das hast du ja auch schon gesagt, Gritz. Bei der Weltmeisterschaft hat die FIFA die Explosivität, dass das Topinkontrollsystem von vorn bis hinten beeinflusst. Bei der Europameisterschaft die UEFA. Und im deutschen Fußball war das lange Zeit auch so, dass der DFB tatsächlich auch die Topinkontrollen durchgeführt hat und sich das erst in den letzten Jahren gewandelt hat. Wobei da immer noch die Entscheidung über, was passiert sozusagen am Ende, das Ergebnismanagement, beim Topinkontrollablauf, das macht immer noch der DFB. Also, das ist jetzt kein reines Weltmeisterschaftsproblem. Das wollte ich nur anklarschneiden.
Aber wissen wir denn, Jonathan, wie jetzt die Kontrollen vor Ort in Russland ablaufen? Was wissen wir eigentlich über Antik-Doping-Maßnahmen jetzt rund um diese WM?
Also, meine Einschätzung ist, dass wir so wenig wissen wie lange nicht mehr. Das war in der Vergangenheit auch schwierig. Aber damals in den beiden letzten EMS und WMs war es zumindest so, dass von meiner Erfahrung, dass auf Presseanfragen sogar relativ ausführlich geantwortet wurde. Dazu gab es auch noch Presseerklärungen zu dem ganzen Bereich Doping, sodass man so ganz minimale Ausschnitte, zumindest ein paar Zahlen, bekommen hat. Dieses Jahr war es für mich so. Vielleicht haben andere Journalisten andere Erfahrungen gemacht, dass ich zum ersten Mal gar keine Antworten bekommen habe. Den Stand, den ich jetzt habe, ist nur, dass die FIFA gesagt hat, es gab sozusagen vor dem Turnierbeginn seit Januar bis zum Anstoß 2700 Doping-Kontrollen. Mit der Zahl kann man jetzt erst mal ziemlich wenig anfangen, weil es schwer zu begreifen ist, wie viele Nationalspieler sind da drunter. Da waren ja die Kader noch gar nicht festgelegt. Dazu gab es noch Kontrollen in Ländern, die ganz unterschiedliches Niveau haben.
Das hört sich aber erst mal noch viel an, oder?
Ja, absolute Zahlen hören sich oft viel an. Sonst würden die, glaube ich, gar nicht kompensiert werden.
Soll ich mal ganz kurz einen Satz rein? Es gibt 100.000 Profifußballer weltweit. Also, wenn man das mal so sagt, und die machen 2700 Kontrollen, die FIFA. So relativieren sich die absoluten Zahlen.
Dann haben wir den Stand im Turnier. Vielleicht macht es Sinn, dass man das kurz chronologisch durchgeht, was jetzt im Turnier passiert gerade. Grit, wenn du etwas zu ergänzen hast, komm einfach rein an der Stelle. Meine Kenntnisstand, es gibt die ganz klassischen Kontrollen nach einem Spiel. Das wird dann meistens eine Halbzeit ausgelost, zwei Spieler pro Team, die danach dann in die Kabine begleitet werden. Wie viele Kontrollen zusätzlich, also zwischen den Spielen stattfinden, das ist eine Zahl, die mir gar nicht bekannt ist.
Ich gehe mal kurz rein. 2014 gab es das gar nicht. Da haben sie während des Turniers nur die nach dem Spiel gemacht. Also wie du das gerade beschrieben hast, Jonathan, ausgelost. Und dann zur Doping-Kontrolle, was natürlich ein Witz ist. Denn am Spieltag dobst du nicht, du dobst in den Regenerationstagen dazwischen. Und es gibt Substanzen, die haben Nachweis, Zeitfenster, manche acht Stunden, manche 20 Stunden. Also nach dem Spiel zu kontrollieren ist Alibi und nichts anderes.
Auch die Ratsportler haben gerne an ihrem Ruhetag gedobt. Also nicht dort, wo sie gefahren sind. Ja, da kann man das immer ganz gut merken. Und dann ist die Frage für mich, wenn wir beim Spieltag noch kurz bleiben, wo wir wissen, dass Kontrollen stattfinden, da gibt es immer die Frage, wie gelangen die Spieler vom Feld zu dem Kontrollraum, sodass sie auch, auch wenn es unwahrscheinlich ist, dass sie da gedobt haben, die Probe dann nicht manipulieren können. Und da gibt es ja dieses Chaperon-System. Und war es so, dass eigentlich vor der WM das so definiert war, dass das WM-Organisationskomitee, die über die ganzen Volunteers, die sie da in Russland haben, diese Chaperon auch mitbestimmt, die da unterwegs sind, das hat die FIFA jetzt an sich gerissen, haben sie gesagt, jedenfalls vor dem Turnier. Für mich ist aber völlig unbekannt dazu, und es soll auch keine Frage beantworten, wer das jetzt eigentlich macht. Ist eh immer schwierig, wenn es Volunteers machen, und man nicht weiß, sind die jetzt eher Fans oder wirklich Beobachter, die Ronaldo trauen, zu sagen, du kannst jetzt hier nicht einfach im Nebenraum verschwinden oder so. Aber das ist sozusagen eine Frage, die für mich nicht gekehrt ist. Und dann ist die Frage, wie der Transportweg dann danach passiert bei den wenigen Proben, die genommen werden. Jetzt ist es so wie in Rio damals, wie bei Brasilien damals, bei WM 2014, dass die Proben eine lange Reise haben, denn es gibt wieder kein akkreditiertes Anti-Doping-Labor. Das war damals auch schon so. Basierend ist diesmal noch ein bisschen offensichtlicher die Gründe durch das ganze russische Doping-System. Das heißt, hier oben hat man eine lange Reise. Da kann man jetzt Fragen stellen, wer sichert eigentlich diese Reise, dass die Kühlkette nicht unterbrochen wird, zum Beispiel, dass Flaschen nicht manipulierbar sind. Und dann dazu die Frage, steht eigentlich das Ergebnis, gerade in der Gruppenphase, stand das immer bis zum nächsten Spiel schon fest? Da gibt es ja bestimmt Abläufe, dann Widerspruchsrecht, dass dann die B-Probe erst noch geöffnet wird. Also da braucht man schon mal ein paar Stunden, wenn nicht sogar ein paar Tage, um zu einem Ergebnis zu gelangen. Das sind für mich alles offene Fragen auf dieser Reise der Kontrollen. Und dann der letzte Schritt ist die Frage, was im Labor genau passiert, also auf welche Substanzen wird eine Probe eigentlich alles untersucht. Unser Kollege Heio Seppelt hat gestern ein Interview gegeben, wo er noch mal gesagt hat, es gibt so eine Liste von der WADA, vielleicht weiß Grit sogar den Namen, sozusagen auch definiert wird, wie oft bestimmte Substanzen kontrolliert werden sollen. Und er hatte da noch mal darauf hingewiesen, jede zehnte Probe wird nur auf Wachstumshormone zum Beispiel getestet, was ich jetzt spontan sehr wenig fand. Also das muss viel schneller wachsen können.
Das ist die WADA-Testing-Statistik, also für der Jahresbericht, der hat über 300 Seiten. Der letzte ist für das Jahr 2016 und das habe ich natürlich auch nicht im Kopf, aber das habe ich mir gestern noch mal in Vorbereitung auf unser Gespräch hier angeguckt. Da ist es zum Beispiel so, dass im Fußball insgesamt 33.000 Kontrollen sind. Das ist absolut gesehen viel, aber auch die wenigsten verdächtigen Proben, weniger als im Segeln und etwa derselbe Wert wie im Golf, 1, 5 Prozent. Aber interessant ist, dass wir zum Beispiel deutlich weniger Bluttests als in der Leichtathletik haben. Also nicht Bluttests. Ich sage jetzt mal nach den Substanzen, das haben wir auch. Aber die Substanzen, die gesucht werden im Fußball. Wir gehen mal davon aus, dass du Epo ganz gut brauchen könntest, wenn du 114 Kilometer rennst im Spiel. Da wird also im Fußball gerade mal in 4200 Proben nach Epo gesucht, in der Leichtathletik in über 10.000 Proben. Und so geht das weiter. Also nach dem insulinähnlichen Wachstumsfaktor IGF-A, ein wichtiges Dopingmittel, wenn du Fettanteil im Körper zugunsten von Muskelwachstum zum Beispiel reduzierst, das hat viele Vorteile, wird im Fußball 31 Mal in 31 Proben gesucht, im ganzen Jahr in der Leichtathletik in über 200. Und noch ein Spaß, wenn wir an Fuentes denken, der hat ja Bluttransfusion gemacht im Radsport. Und wie es dann hieß, hatte er eben auch Klienten aus dem Fußball. Der spanische Doping-Doktor im Fußball ist im Jahr 2016. Du kannst inzwischen Bluttransfusionen nachweisen. In der Leichtathletik immerhin 162 Mal nach Transfusionen gesucht worden, im Fußball gar nicht. Und so geht das weiter. Die gucken nach Steroiden im Fußball, in den meisten, also überwiegend. Und das ist, damit kannst du immer noch dopen, aber die sind auch leicht nachweisbar. Es gibt auch die meisten Fälle, die meisten positiven Proben sind Steroide. Aber nach Epo und ähnlichen Geschichten oder nach Wachstumshormonen oder gar nach Bluttransfusionen wird es, wenn ich mal die zwei andere Hochrisikosportarten nehme, Rad- und Leichtathletik wird jeweils deutlich, deutlich weniger gesucht. Also das ist klar, die schützen sich auch so. Das siehst du an solchen Statistiken.
Ja, und jetzt sind wir sozusagen die ganze Kette einmal durchgegangen. Unser Ergebnis ist wahrscheinlich extrem unwahrscheinlich, dass überhaupt eine positive Probe zustande kommt. Jetzt haben wir trotzdem noch den letzten Schritt, dass die FIFA entscheidet, was denn mit einem positiven Test passieren würde. Das muss man auch mal sehen, weil sie das Ergebnis mit einen Schritt machen. Klar könnte die WADA irgendwie Einspruch einlegen. Das müssen sie sich aber schon sehr genau überlegen. Darüber haben wir ja gesprochen, über das Geld im Fußball. Und ich finde gerade, wenn man das in Russland nochmal so nachvollzieht, allein schon mit dem Transportweg, dieser Kühlkette und alles, dann sehe ich schon als fast Laie, also nun wirklich als kein Jurist, schon Hebel, wo ich dann einen positiven Test anzweifeln könnte. Und mit ein, zwei Gutachten oder einem klugen Anwalt kann man, glaube ich, ganz gut dann auch was anfechten, wenn es denn überhaupt dazu kommen würde. In den letzten Doping-Tests wurde, glaube ich, auch schon oft genug gesagt, aber ist immer gut zur Erinnerung, gab es ja bei einer Weltmeisterschaft 1994 mit Maradona. Das letzte Mal ist es auch schon ein bisschen her.
Aber noch mal dazu, auch da kommt es wieder auf Personen drauf an. Ja, die werden in Lausanne alle getestet, alle in einem Labor bzw. geprüft, die Proben. Und dort gab es einen Laborleiter, Marcial Soujy, der das seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr ist, weil er unter anderem russische Dopingproben vernichtet hat entgegen der Anweisung der FIFA, weil er plötzlich in Sochi als im Auftrag des russischen Sportministeriums arbeitete, dort im Doping-Kontroll-Labor. Und dieser Marcial Soujy, also ein äußerst umstrittener Anti-Doping-Mensch, ehemaliger Lausanner Laborchef, der ist jetzt der Special Advisor für die FIFA in Anti-Doping-Geschichten. Daran siehst du also wieder, auf wie vielen Ebenen man da wirklich allergrößte Zweifel haben kann. Und ich würde sogar so weit gehen, egal was die uns erzählen, was sie alles gemacht haben und auch was sie uns nicht erzählen, worauf genau sie testen. Glauben musst du nichts, solange es keine unabhängigen Berater gibt. Also es gibt keinen Grund, der FIFA irgendetwas abzunehmen, was sie mitteilt, solange sie keine Überprüfung, die wenigstens im Ansatz unabhängig ist, nämlich der war da zulässt.
Und andere Sportarten haben das ja auch zugelassen. Selbst im Ratsport, den Vergleich hatten wir ja vorhin, gab es irgendwann den Zeitpunkt, ich glaube 2010 war das, wenn ich das so richtig erholt habe, wo die ASO, das sind die Veranstalter bei der Tour de France, gesagt haben, ja dieses Jahr darf die Vardar mal dabei sein. Dann haben sie einen Report später veröffentlicht, ein paar Monate später. Dann bei den Olympischen Spielen in Rio 2016 gab es auch die Vardars beobachtet, die den Report danach veröffentlicht haben. Ist jetzt auch nicht so, wie FIFA vermutlich beim Fußball der einzige Verband, die das noch nie zugelassen haben, oder?
Ja, also ich weiß, bei der Leichtathletik gibt es auch unabhängige Beobachter, das ist ganz klar. Bei anderen Sportarten habe ich mich jetzt noch nicht so irre dafür interessiert. Aber dort ist es eben auch schon so, dass sie selbstverständlich – und da waren wir ja schon mal, können wir nochmal kurz zurückspringen – alle nicht ihre eigenen Kontrolleure haben, sondern von verschiedenen Anti-Doping-Organisationen. Also Leichtathletik Europameisterschaft findet und selbstverständlich bringt da der europäische Leichtathletikverband nicht eigene Kontrolleure mit, sondern die NADA wird kontrollieren, die deutsche nationale Anti-Doping-Agentur. Und so geht das immer nur bei der FIFA nicht. Und da muss man wirklich schichten, einfach ganz scharf muss man die WADA dafür kritisieren. Also, dass sie der FIFA einen solchen Sonderstatus einräumt, das geht nicht. Und normalerweise, sie hat ja die Macht sozusagen, einen auch Sportverband, incompliant, also nicht, wie sagt man, wie sagen wir das jetzt, also nicht Konkurrent oder nicht den WADA-Code erfüllend zu erklären, wie sie das mit der russischen Anti-Doping-Agentur gemacht hat, kann sie das auch mit Weltverbänden machen. Und ja, das kann sie bei der FIFA tun, ja. Aber es wird ja dieses Gespräch geben, wie wir jetzt wissen.
Dann setzen wir mal alle Hoffnung auf dieses Gespräch. Also, wir haben jetzt ein bisschen herausgearbeitet. Der Fußball hat eine besondere Stellung im Anti-Doping-Kampf, wo ich dann Kampf in große Anführungszeichen setzen würde, nach dem, was ihr jetzt alles aufgearbeitet habt. Dann haben wir auch am Fall Guerrero schon gesehen, selbst die Fälle, die es gibt, sind alle nicht so einfach zu betrachten. Und es ist auch nicht klar, ob da die Sportgerichtsbarkeit und die Formalitäten alle stimmen. Und wir wissen sehr, sehr wenig über die genauen Abläufe in Russland selbst und ob das alles so unangreifbar ist. Jonathan, dann bleibt uns ja eigentlich – bleiben einem ja zwei Positionen. Die eine Position ist, dass man sagt, der Fußball ist wunderbar sauber, alles prima, es gibt nichts hier zu sehen. Die andere Position ist, wir haben vermutlich berechtigte Zweifel, dass hier alles so sauber abläuft. Ihr habt ja ganz gut herausgearbeitet. Dann können wir ja nur Dinge beobachten. Gibt es denn Dinge, die du bei dieser WM beobachten konntest, die dich skeptisch machen, dass da ohne Doping ein Fußballturnier vonstatten geht oder ohne gedopte Spiele?
Ja, ich gehe also fest davon aus, dass bei dieser WM gedoppt wird, um das immer in einen Einsatz zusammenzubringen. Da habe ich keine Zweifel. Jetzt ist es natürlich schwierig, bestimmten Spielern das vorzuwerben. Das wäre auch falsch. Es gibt nur Indizien, an denen man sich lang arbeiten kann, die vielleicht verwundung aussuchen. Dann könnte man da weiter recherchieren. Es gibt diese ganze Vorgeschichte. Da würde ich jetzt nicht tiefer darauf eingehen, was in Russland alles vorher schon zu veröffentlicht wurde. Da können wir aber darüber reden, wenn ihr wollt. Jetzt nur das, was ich beobachte bei der WM. Wir haben das auf Fußball-Doping im Twitter-Kanal ja immer gerne dokumentiert, falls da Leute reingeschaut haben. Und zwar ist das Thema, was alle so ein bisschen beschäftigt, dass Russland das laufstärkste Team der Weltmeisterschaft ist. Was man aber erst mal auf dem ersten Blick nur an den gelaufenen Kilometern sieht und was vielleicht auch in seiner Aussagekraft begrenzt ist. Also wenn man das in Relation setzt zu anderen Turnieren, zur Bundesliga, Premier League, dann sind die Zahlen gar nicht so außergewöhnlich. Wenn Russland selbst wie gegen Saudi-Arabien, da wurde der Rekordwert erreicht mit 118 Kilometern, da so viel läuft, das ist in der Bundesliga sogar Gang und Gebe so ein Wert, das ist ein bisschen schwierig, das in Relation zu setzen. Dazu gibt es ja auch Studien, dass man tatsächlich mit dem Heimvorteil mehr läuft und so Geschichten. Da würde ich auch viele Gegenargumente verstehen. Was ich mir außergewöhnlich finde, wirklich nur vom Fernsehsessel aus, wo ich zwischendurch immer gerne in diese Vielverlaufsstatistiken reinschaue, dass die Zahlen zeigen, dass viele Mannschaften tatsächlich nicht schwächer werden mit Laufe der Spielzeit und Russland ganz vorne mit dabei. Also wenn man mal das Spiel Russland gegen Spanien sieht, dann gab es tatsächlich keinen Einbruch in der Verlängerung. Das kennt man ja auch von vergangenen Turnieren, dass dann irgendwann man das Gefühl hat, den Mannschaften ist wirklich den Spielern die Puste ausgegangen. Und das Belegen zeigen die Zahlen, dass das diesmal wirklich nicht passiert ist. Es gibt zwar jetzt die Möglichkeit, einen vierten Spieler einzuwechseln und so, aber ich glaube, das erklärt es nicht allein. Bei dem Spiel Spanien gegen Russland war es so, dass beide Mannschaften aus Spanien in der zweiten Halbzeit der Verlängerung sogar noch mehr gelaufen sind, als in der ersten Halbzeit der Verlängerung. Und das finde ich erstmal interessant als Beobachter. Interessant finde ich auch, auf die Sprintwerte zu schauen. Das ist ja sozusagen auf Outdoor die Kilometerwerte und dann die Sprintfähigkeit vielleicht sogar noch interessanter. Wer da viel unterwegs ist. Und da hat Russland einen, besonders einen herausragenden Spieler mit Golovinen, der wirklich jedes Spiel außergewöhnlich viel gesprintet ist. Also im ersten Spiel – wir haben schon ganz schön viele Zahlen genannt. Das ist ja Audio immer ein bisschen schwierig. Ich hoffe, viele haben Zettel dabei, damit sie an den Stellen mitkommen. Ja, entschuldige ich mich mal an unser beide Namen mit den Zahlen. Aber es ist halt viele Sachen, die lassen sich faktisch nur an Zahlen lang argumentieren. Also nur, dass man ein Gefühl bekommt. Also der Golovinen war immer der Spieler bei Russland, der mit Abstand am meisten gesprintet ist. Ist natürlich auch dem Spielsystem geschult, ist mir klar. Aber gegen Saudi-Arabien waren es 69 Sprints in gut 90 Minuten. Also meistens sind es ja so 95 bis 97 Minuten. Dann gegen Ägypten 72 Sprints, wo Russland schon deutlich weniger gelaufen ist. Danach wurde er nicht eingesetzt. Und gegen Spanien waren es noch mal mehr als, oder waren es glaube ich genau 60 Sprints. Da hat er sogar das magische Triple, so habe ich es mal genannt, auf das Fußballing erreicht. Er ist am meisten gelaufen seiner Mannschaft. 16 Kilometer, war der schnellste Spieler. Also an irgendeiner Stelle ist er irgendwie 33 kmh oder so gelaufen. Und dann hat er auch noch am meisten gesprintet. Also der Mann hat echt Power gehabt. So Sachen beobachte ich jetzt gerne. Da muss man aufpassen mit voreiligen Schlüssen. Aber das kann ja ein Ansatzpunkt sein für weitere Recherchen.
Und gibt es da auch andere Mannschaften, andere Nationalitäten? Ist es gerechtfertigt, dass wir alle vielleicht, ich nehme uns jetzt mal alle drei in ein Boot, da auch besonders auf Russland blicken, weil man da eben einfach durch das aufgedeckte Staatsdoping und viele Erkenntnisse, die man bei Russland hat, die bei anderen Ländern fehlen, schon viel weiß. Und vielleicht deswegen da auch einen besonderen Blick drauf hat. Ist dir auch bei anderen Nationalitäten was aufgefallen?
Na, zum Beispiel bei England gegen Kolumbien wurde nicht weniger gelaufen als bei Spanien gegen Russland. Also das muss man auch, auf jeden Fall, das habe ich aber auch schon gesagt, mit den Kilometern, dass da die Aussagekraft begrenzt ist. Also wenn man das jetzt allein sehen würde, dann kann man das nicht nehmen. Russland hat ja wirklich auch ein außergewöhnliches Spielsystem, wo du sehr defensiv machst, da weißt du viel besser Bescheid dazu. Und ich kann es ein paar Sätze zu sagen, die Laufleistung ist ja auch dem System geschuldet, man muss es aber trotzdem bis zum Ende rennen können und vor allem auch nach Verlängerung und den entscheidenden Phasen des Spiels. Das finde ich muss man immer sehen. Und da gibt es auf jeden Fall auch andere Mannschaften, die eine besondere Laufleistung erbringen, aber ich finde, der Teufel steckt dann sozusagen wieder in Detail. Ich finde es aber rechtfertig, dass man bei Russland besonders hinschaut, einfach wegen der ganzen großen Vorgeschichte. Man darf aber dann nicht den Fehler machen, dass man die Sachen zu einfach interpretiert. Und es gab ja diese Diskussionen rund um, haben wir als Fußball-Doping auch zu beigetragen, dass es so ein paar Fernsehbilder gab, der eine schnüffelt an so einer Flasche mit Ammoniak, wurde jedenfalls später gesagt. Dann gibt es diese Fotos von Spielern, die irgendwelche Injektionen bekommen haben, wo der Arzt später meinte, das war eine ganz normale Blutabnahme. Da muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein. Warum sollten Spieler an aller Öffentlichkeit seinen Doping so präsentieren? Da ist man sicherlich bei Russland gerade viele Menschen besonders darauf fixiert, dort irgendwelche Ansatzpunkte für mögliches Doping zu finden. Dann ist das natürlich sehr einseitig getrieben. Das könnte man bei anderen Mannschaften sicherlich auch finden.
Ich meine, dass es absolut berechtigt ist, sich alles anzuschauen und die Fragen auch zu stellen. Die Kreuzungen gibt es im Spitzenfußball immer öfter. Die Ausdauersprinter, wie du gerade den einen beschrieben hast, das deutet schon auf was hin. Solche Fähigkeiten zu entwickeln, es gibt schlicht und einfach natürliche Grenzen und Ausdauer und Sprintvermögen so zu verbinden, das ist etwas sehr fußballspezifisches. Auch, dass die Limits immer höher werden. Aber ansonsten stimme ich euch vollkommen zu, daraus allein kannst du noch nichts ableiten, angucken darfst du es. Aber da habe ich jetzt nicht die Sprintanalysen da, aber angeguckt habe ich mir schon noch mal. Wer ist 2014 am meisten gelaufen? 115, 3 Kilometer pro Spiel. Also ich würde sagen, man muss auf Russland besonders gucken. Solche Daten sind teilweise, glaube ich, auch durch Motivation zu erklären, können zu erklären sein. Es ist trotzdem wichtig. Ich würde sagen, solche Daten, wie es sie von Russland gibt, von Spanien, auch von Kolumbien, sind ein Zeichen dafür und Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass man im gesamten Fußball, Spitzenfußball, ganz genau hingucken muss. Und Kontrollen, die FIFA hat im letzten Jahr 750 Kontrollen genommen, weltweit. Das ist lächerlich. Davon ein bisschen über 60 Blutproben. Die bringen noch nicht mal alles, weil es viele Mittel gibt, die nicht nachweisbar sind. Aber wenn irgendwo richtig gut gedobt wird, weil es entsprechendes Geld vorhanden ist, sich Mediziner leisten zu können, sich bestimmte Mittel leisten zu können, dann können wir davon ausgehen, dass das im Fußball stattfindet. Und dafür sind solche Daten ein Anhaltspunkt. Und nicht nur bei den Russen, auch bei denen. Aber die Leistungsentwicklung im Fußball, wie viel dynamischer er geworden ist, mit jedem Jahrzehnt in den letzten drei, vier Jahrzehnten, also das zeigt eigentlich, was da los ist. Und das ist nicht rein physiologisch.
Es könnte natürlich auch viel, viel besseres Training als früher sein und bessere Ernährung und so weiter. Also wenn ich jetzt mit einem Sportler sprechen würde oder mit einem Funktionär, dann würden da ganz bestimmt diese Argumente kommen. Ja, die Infrastruktur ist ja was ganz anderes, das Spiel ist ein anderes, die Leute ernähren sich anders als früher. Kann man es nicht auch allein damit erklären?
Ich würde sagen, das habe ich in der DDR, für die DDR auch immer gehört, die haben so super Trainingsmethoden, deshalb sind die so klasse. Und gewinnen, räumen alles ab im Schwimmen oder sonst wo. Und sie da, das waren nicht die Trainingsmethoden, es war Doping. Und jetzt ist tatsächlich das eigentlich schlagende Argument, das ist, glaube ich, der stärkste Anhaltspunkt, das sind diese Studien, die veröffentlicht werden, wo es also Werte zwischen 25 und 40 Prozent von Fußballern gibt, die sagen, ja, ich habe schon mal gedoppt, ja. Worüber wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, ist der extreme, und der ist nun nicht illegal, aber das ist im Fußball wie in keiner anderen olympischen Sportart der extreme Konsum von Schmerzmitteln im Fußball, ja. Und auch das kannst du als Indikator nehmen, wie groß die Bereitschaft ist, über Grenzen zu gehen, ja. Und das ist im Fußball wirklich hochgradig gesundheitsgefährdend für die Spieler, ja. Bei der letzten WM hat man festgestellt, dass 60 Prozent die FIFA selbst aller Spieler regelmäßig Schmerzmittel genommen haben, ja. Und das ist auch aus der Bundesliga bekannt, was sich da abspielt. Es sind alles so Indikatoren, die also gegen die reine Lehre von der verbesserten Trainingsmethodik doch ein bisschen sprechen, ja.
Es gibt ja auch Sportmediziner wie Pierre Klesiemann, von dem du ja vorhin schon gesprochen hast, die auch dann wirklich Experten auf dem Bild sind und gesagt haben, da weiß ich nicht mehr das genaue Zitat, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her, dass aus seiner Sicht sozusagen das, was man über Training erreichen kann, da gibt es vielleicht nur ein, zwei Prozent, die man noch herauskitzeln kann. Aber da sind wir auch schon ziemlich am Maximum aus seiner Perspektive. Und die sozusagen die letzten Prozentchen oder darüber hinaus, das geht dann tatsächlich nur über Doping. Ich sehe das immer so ein bisschen wie in der Bankenwelt oder sozusagen, wo möchte man das Geld anlegen? Wo kriegt man am meisten Rendite raus? Und ich glaube, die höhere Rendite kriegt man dann einfach hin oder die sichere Rendite, wenn man da ein bisschen riskanter unterwegs ist und in dem Bereich sozusagen investiert. Also das wäre ein Doping in dem Moment. Aber Vergleich hier hinten immer, ich merke das gerade schon wieder an dem Moment, wo ich es ausspreche.
Naja, doch, ich glaube, das macht schon ein bisschen die Abwägung zwischen erwartbarem Gewinn und das dafür eingehende Risiko. Das ist ja schon der richtige Vergleich. Und das macht das schon ein bisschen deutlich. Das zeigt aber auch so ein bisschen, Jonathan, wir stochern doch ganz schön im Dunklen. Also wenn wir jetzt ein paar Sprintwerte uns heranziehen, uns Lauchstatistiken angucken, die man aber – und das habt ihr ja auch schon beide getan – mit anderen Dingen auch begründen kann und die auch miteinander nicht immer vergleichbar sind, dann könnte man jetzt ja auch als unskeptischer Hörer oder Hörerin sagen, ja das ist doch eigentlich so, denn warum geht man denn überhaupt davon aus, dass jetzt auch bei dieser WM zum Beispiel etwas passiert? Wir sitzen doch da im Grunde vor einer Black Box.
Ich glaube, die einfachste Lösung wäre, dass wir journalistisch einfach noch mehr Kapazitäten bekommen, um tiefer recherchieren zu können und mit viel mehr Menschen zu dem Thema sprechen zu können. Also ich denke da besonders an ehemalige Sportler.
Da habt ihr auch schon gute Erfahrungen bei FußballDoping.de gemacht, gell?
Ja, aber auch bei uns, würde ich sagen, wir müssen uns richtig entscheiden, ob man da sozusagen weiter für welches Thema man seine Stunden im Tag hat ein. Das ist ja quasi eine tägliche, wöchentliche oder monatliche Entscheidung, wo man gerade seine Schwerpunkte hat. Und das gibt insgesamt viel mehr. Der Kreis insgesamt der Journalisten, die über den Sportkritisch berichten, ist in Deutschland ja weiterhin relativ überschaubar. Ich habe das Gefühl, es hat sich verbessert. Grit hat da noch ein bisschen besser einen Überblick. Aber trotzdem geht da viel mehr. Was ich besonders, wo ich sozusagen eine große Chance sehen würde, ist, dass da auch mehrere Journalisten im Verbund zusammenarbeiten und über den Bereich kritischer Berichten. Du hattest uns im Vorfeld mal die Frage gestellt, ich weiß nicht, ob du darauf hinaus willst, ob du auch findest, dass in der WM-Berichterstattung das Doping-Thema insgesamt mehr eingebunden werden müsste. Das würde ich an der Stelle kurz aufgreifen, wenn mir das jetzt nicht passt. Das hat damit auf jeden Fall was zu tun. Wenn ich sehe, wie viel Sendezeitsverfügung steht bei der WM. Ich habe das jetzt nicht so intensiv verfolgt, weil ich zwei Wochen in der WM in Italien verbracht habe. Aber das kennt man auch von vergangenen Turnieren und aus der Entfernung konnte ich es auch beobachten. Und dann sozusagen Relation setzt, wie viel von der Sendezeit wird sozusagen für den Bereich Entertainment, was ja berechtigt ist auch bei Fußball, es soll ja Freude machen, auch die WM-Zuschauen eingesetzt. Und wie viel davon für sozusagen Recherche und die Ergebnisse von Recherchen, dann finde ich das weiterhin erschreckend wenig. Auch wenn ich glaube, dass dieser WM so viel über Doping gesprochen wird im Fußball, wie es bisher noch nie der Fall war bei vergangenen WMs, was aber, glaube ich, einfach allein dem staatlich aufgedeckten russischen Doping, an dem Doping-System liegt, daran hangelt sich das ja auch so ein bisschen lang. Und dann diese Laufwerte, über die wir gesprochen haben und so, das ploppt jetzt immer mal wieder auf. Aber da gibt es jetzt auch keine zusätzlichen Recherchen. Außer vielleicht ein bisschen alledoping, Redaktion, SZ, so ein bisschen asyl-deutsche Zeitung. Aber jetzt auch nicht die großen Sachen, die jetzt während der WM passieren. Es war gerade ein kleines Plädoyer an mehr Färscho und das Redaktion auch, sich entscheidend und wirklich kapazierten Geld Zeit zu investieren.
Aber es wäre auch einfach, um es mal ein bisschen deutlicher zu sagen. Also, ich meine, wir haben monatliche Football-Writer, sogenannte, die da in Russland jetzt sind. Und ich habe mir mal ein paar dieser Pressekonferenzen im Stream angesehen. Es gab, wenn ich – ich habe selbstverständlich nicht alle gesehen, außer ein Kollege Johannes Ohmweiler von der Süddeutschen, der dort auch mal nach solche Fragen gestellt hat, was das zum Beispiel war, woran der russische Spieler geschnüffelt hat und so was. Es gibt keine Journalisten, die Fragen stellen, die irgendetwas mit Doping zu tun haben könnten, wenn sie dort sind. Das sind die absoluten Ausnahmen. Und das heißt, auch im Fußball, das sehe ich wirklich so, ist dieser Typ des Sportjournalisten der berühmte Fan, der es über die Absperrung geschafft hat, immer noch sehr viel ausgeprägter als anderswo. Und es gibt Gelegenheiten, dort zu Fragen nach bestimmten Dingen. Das wird aber nicht gemacht. Ich meine, es gab die Dokumentation von Hajo, Brasilien und Guerrero, wo sich eine Kollegin in die Mixtone gestellt hat und versucht hat, ihn zu konfrontieren. Sehr gut, wie war das? Aber es gibt Gelegenheiten, die werden nicht wahrgenommen. Das heißt nicht, dass ich dort unendlich was aufdecken kann, aber ich bekomme zumindest einen Einblick in die Mentalität über die Reaktionen, die es auf solche Fragen gibt. Das ist ja mit Russland Johannes Aumiller zum Beispiel gelungen, dass eben dort die Auskunft kommt, da bei uns schnüffeln die Spieler Ammoniak und die Haare waschen sich mit Shampoo. Man hat das also sofort verharmlost. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen was anderes, als sich die Haare zu waschen, auch wenn es kein Doping ist. Aber diese Gelegenheit wird sehr wenig genutzt und Jonathan hat völlig recht bei dieser Macht, die der Fußball darstellt und zwar weltweit im professionellen Bereich jedenfalls, helfen, glaube ich, nur Journalistenverbünde und Medienverbünde, öffentlich-rechtliche Sender, private Verlage, die zusammenarbeiten. Sonst wirst du totgemacht sozusagen mit der Macht von Anwälten und Millionen dahinter. Aber das allererste ist mal der Wille, zu fragen und zu recherchieren. Und im Fußball ist der für meine Begriffe. Wir haben Fußball-Doping, Jonathan, die Seite da sind, regelmäßig kann man dazu was nachlesen. Wir haben Fragen gestellt und wir haben einen Kollegen, natürlich Thomas Kissner von der Süddeutschen, der dieses wirklich sehr gute Buch der Schutz – Geheime-Doping-Geschichte des Fußballs vor zwei, drei Jahren veröffentlicht hat. Viel mehr gibt es nicht. Insofern war, glaube ich, Russland nur wichtig, weil man gemerkt hat oder mitbekommen hat, im Fußball funktioniert tatsächlich genauso wie in allen anderen Sportarten. Auch dort ist der Urin ausgetauscht worden, sondern weil es den Blick geweiht hat nochmal genau darauf, wenn das in Russland so ist, dass im Fußball gedobt wird, wie überall anders auch. Warum dann, oder dasselbe System gilt, wieso sollte das woanders anders sein?
Wir haben übrigens überlegt, tatsächlich während der WM auch eine Mini-Recherche zu starten, die man jetzt mal auflegen kann. Wir hatten bei den Volunteers tatsächlich nach Leuten gesucht, die als Schaperon-Arbeit eingesetzt werden. Das war leider nicht erfolgreich, lag vielleicht auch daran, dass die FIFA dann sozusagen entschieden hat. Sie nehmen das doch in ihrer eigenen Hand, obwohl ich davon gesagt habe, dass ich nicht weiß, wer das jetzt am Ende gemacht hat. Aber das wäre ja auch so eine Möglichkeit gewesen, wo man vor Ort wunderbar mal so ein bisschen beobachten kann, was eigentlich passiert. Das kann man ja auch in einem – muss gar keine große Recherche sein. Einfach, es gibt ja, es muss ja jeden Tag was veröffentlicht werden. Es gibt einen Sportmien in der Zeit. Ich hätte gerne einen Text einfach mal gelesen, wo jemand in Ruhe beobachtet, was ein Schaperon sozusagen mit den paar Minuten vor Abpfiff macht, wie er seinen Spieler beobachtet, wann er ihn abgreift, wie viele Minuten dann schon vergangen sind, wie er zum Kontrollraum mitnimmt. Und ich glaube, das kriegt man. Vielleicht höre ich mich da auch, und das ist ganz anders als in der Bundesliga, wo ich so ein bisschen erlebt habe, was in der Mixed-Zone los ist. Aber ich glaube, es wäre eine Geschichte, die man hätte gut machen können. Eine andere Sache, die wir nur nochmal so ein bisschen methodisch rumzuspinnen. Wir haben das ja bei letzten EM gemacht, dass wir einen Kollegen hatten, der ich glaube, an vier Standorten war für Nationalmannschaften und da in die Mülle einmal reingeschaut hat. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht die schönste Methode, ein bisschen adaptiert von Journalisten, die es bei Tour de France früher gemacht haben. In einem Fall hat er ja auch etwas gefunden bei der Ukraine, bei der Nationalmannschaft. Er hat dann da irgendwelche Schmerzmittel und andere Substanzen gefunden und irgendwelche Beutel, wo nicht ganz klar war, war das jetzt nur Glucose oder noch andere Sachen, die da als Infusion irgendwelche Spieler bekommen haben. Ich glaube, da wäre vor Ort, also auch so von den Recherchmethodiken her, ziemlich viel noch möglich. Also die Ausrede, Grit hat einen großen Grund genannt. Bei Pressekonferenz kann man sowieso alles stellen. Das ist sozusagen die eine große Chance. Aber auch so gibt es sozusagen methodisch noch weitere Gründe. Und ich lasse da auch nicht die Ausrede gelten. Wir kommen ja kaum ran vor Ort. Das ist, finde ich, zu wenig. Es gibt immer irgendwelche Möglichkeiten, dann auch vor Ort Recherchen umzusetzen, die man vorher ja auch der Zeitklappheit vor Ort dann planen kann und dann an einem Tag auch mal umsetzen kann.
Gut, aber das eine ist ja jetzt quasi dann die journalistische Arbeit vor Ort. Das andere ist die aktuell stattfindende Berichterstattung. Und da finde ich, ist man schon beim Thema Doping im Fußball ein bisschen in einem Dilemma. Also ich schaffe es hier im Rasenfunk immer wieder, das Thema stattfinden zu lassen. Aber auch in der Sendung zum Beispiel meandern wir eigentlich um die WM so ein bisschen herum. Wir haben es jetzt hoffentlich ganz gut aufgearbeitet, was da interessant zu wissen ist für die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen. Aber man hat ein bisschen ein Henne-Eye-Problem. Dadurch, dass es eine solche Blackbox ist und dass man gerade keine aktuellen neuen Erkenntnisse hat – vielleicht reden wir gleich noch ganz kurz über das, was Howard Sapplet aufgedeckt hat rund um die WM – aber darüber hinaus gibt es so arg viel weniges – kann man dann eher immer so das machen, was wir jetzt auch gemacht haben. Hinweisen auf, da hat ein russischer Spieler direkt vor seiner Einwechslung an etwas geschnüffelt. Da gab es ein Stichlöcher und die Antwort, das haben wir, um seine Leistungswerte zu bestimmen, abgezogen. Da kann man hinterfragen, muss man das wirklich an der Vene machen oder macht man das nicht häufiger am Ohrläppchen? Könnte man Mediziner zu befragen? Aber es gibt ja sehr, sehr wenig Konkretes, über das man berichten könnte. Außer dessen – und das hätte ich mir auch wirklich gewünscht, auch in der Berichterstattung vor allem der Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, die eben einfach die größte Reichweite im Fernsehen haben – dass man mal beschreibt, wie ist eigentlich das Doping-System im Fußball, also das Anti-Doping-System aufgebaut. Das, was wir jetzt im ersten Teil dieser Sendung gemacht haben, weil ich glaube, da gibt es auch noch große Wissenslücken bei den Fußballkonsumentinnen und Konsumenten. Vielleicht ist es ihnen auch egal, aber zumindest sollte man es ihnen schon mal erzählen. Du übrigens, hier läuft das nach komplett anderen Regeln, nach den eigenen Regeln des Fußballs, als in vielen anderen Sportarten. Aber ansonsten hat man ja wirklich dieses Problem, worüber soll man sprechen? Und wenn man das Thema immer wieder nur mit so einer moralischen Keule bringt, dann setzen da ja auch Ermüdungserscheinungen ein bei den Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörern.
Es ist schon richtig, Max, aber Jonathan hat ja angefangen, ein paar Themenvorschläge sozusagen zu machen, die aber nicht stattfinden während dieser WM. Also es gibt noch eine ganz andere Beitrag über die Mannschaftsärzte, die dort beim Fußball unterwegs sind. Also zum Beispiel der Mannschaftsarzt der Engländer war schon in Doping-Ermittlungen verwickelt. Ja, habe ich in Deutschsprachigkeit einen Beitrag drüber gelesen, englischsprachig einen, glaube ich. Also es gibt dort wirklich viele Zugänge. Man muss es nur wollen. Und das passiert nicht. Du kannst natürlich nicht – wir können leider bei einer WM keine Doping- Fälle aufdecken. Das liegt nicht in unserer Macht. Also wir wissen nicht, was bei den Tests rauskommt. Das ist die Blackbox. Und wir wissen auch nicht, ob Doping-Fälle verschleiert werden oder sonst was. Die Strukturen kannst du darstellen, wie du richtig sagst. Aber ich bin der festen Aufüberzeugung, es gibt auch dort viele Möglichkeiten. Sie werden aber nicht wahrgenommen. Und das liegt natürlich zum Teil daran, dass es sich um – wenn du Fernsehen ansprichst – um Rechteverwerter handelt. Aber da würde ich mich jetzt ein bisschen wehren wollen. Also nicht nur, weil ich für die ARD arbeite, aber da gab es immerhin tatsächlich die Sendung von Haio dazu. Ob das nun genug ist und man während der WM dort auch vielleicht mit anderen Kollegen noch was anderes hätte machen können, darüber spreche ich jetzt mal nicht. Das ZDF hat – gab es einen sehr schönen Beitrag von Markus Ham, der mal aus einer anderen Blackbox beschaffen ist. Das waren nur vier Minuten, aber immerhin zwar da. Mir fehlt das ehrlich gesagt bei den hunderten Zeitungs- und Rundfunkjournalisten mindestens genauso wie beim Fernsehen. Da ist schlicht und einfach nicht genug Neugier da. Man will sich nicht anlegen. All das, was da mitspielt und was eigentlich nicht zu unserem Beruf gehören sollte. Ich finde auch nicht, dass wir nur spekulieren. Wir sagen ja schon ganz klar, wo die wunden Punkte sind im Fußball. Wir können auf Umfragen hinweisen, wir können auf bestimmte Leistungsparameter hinweisen. Wir können auch, da war immer noch gar nicht gesprochen, dass es noch was kannte, als die Leistungsparameter zu beobachten. Das ist auch ein Problem, wenn man sich die körperlichen Entwicklungen von Spielern anguckt, sieht man da schon was. Da gibt es Spieler, die keinen Körperfett mehr haben. Da gibt es Spieler, die vor vier Jahren völlig anders aussahen als sie jetzt. Jetzt sind sie mit Muskeln vollgepackt und das sind nicht nur Stürmer. Das ist auch sehr riskant, aber auch da kannst du etwas sehen. Das sind nicht nur Spekulationen, sondern auch die, die du machen musst und kannst, wenn du über Doping sprichst. Wenn du das kombinierst mit dem Test, dann ergibt sich ein klares Bild.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass der Zuschauer müde ist. Das ist nicht meine Erfahrung. Ich rede jetzt öfters mit Leuten über das Thema. Wenn die irgendwie hören, ich mache Fußball-Doping, kommt immer weiterhin die erste Frage, ob das überhaupt Sinn macht. Über ein Jahrzehnt gestreckt jetzt fast. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass du an irgendeiner Stelle die öffentliche Aufklärung zu dem Punkt gekommen bist, wo diese Frage nicht mehr gestellt werden muss. Auch bei Interviews ist das, wenn man irgendwo ein Radio-Interview gibt, meistens immer noch die erste Frage. Klar, Leute, die jetzt unseren Vier-Stunden-Podcast gehört haben und heute wieder zugehört haben, die werden an ein paar Stellen richtig zuhören, verstehe ich total. Aber ich glaube, in der breiten Öffentlichkeit ist das weiterhin nicht so angekommen. Also diese Basisbegründung, da würde es auch schon helfen, wenn so eine Dokumentation wie die von Hajo Seppelt gesendet wurde, nicht nachts läuft, sondern zu einer prominenteren Sendezeit. Man hat ja genug Möglichkeiten, gerade nach dem Ausscheiden von Deutschland vielleicht auch, wo man andere Themen platzieren kann. Oder auch einfach mal, es müssen auch nicht die großen Recherchen sein. Es reicht ja auch, wenn ein kritischer Geist eingeladen wird. Es gibt ja genug Interviewformate, der einfach mal zu dem Thema mit einer Viertelstunde befragt wird. Wenn dann sozusagen zwischen den drei Herren mal so hin und her moderiert wird in der ARD, dann kann ja irgendwer von den drei noch mal abgeben zum Interview mit Perricle Simon oder jemand anderem, der sich vielleicht als Gegenwart noch dazu äußern möchte.
Ja, sehr gerne auch mal eine Frau. Dann haben wir auch noch mehr Frauen in der Berichterstattung. Hätten wir hier zum Beispiel eine in der Runde gehabt, die auch dazu gestunden hätte, sicher. Ich stelle mal die Frage dir, Jonathan, weil ich weiß, dass Grit auch schon viel mit Hajo Seppett zusammengearbeitet hat. Wie wichtig ist denn dann so eine Figur wie Hajo Seppett mit seinen Dokumentationen, die jetzt im Laufe der WM rauskam und der ja auch ein bundesweites Interesse hervorgerufen hat, dadurch, dass ihm erst die Einreise nach Russland verwehrt wurde oder das Visum und er dann entschieden hat, aus Sicherheitsgründen in Deutschland zu bleiben?
Ich glaube, nicht er hat das entschieden, sondern das darf man eher als Anordnung von ARD verstehen. Sie schicken ihren Mann da nicht hin. Aber zu der Frage, klar, also an bestimmten Personen, ich glaube, so ein Narrativ, also Hajo Seppett ist ja fast ein Narrativ geworden zu dem Thema, ist schon wichtig, um sozusagen die Leute auch mal wieder daran erinnern zu können, dass das ein Thema ist. Und es ist auch wichtig, dass dadurch sozusagen die Möglichkeit entwickelt wurde, dass Hajo Seppett jetzt auch wirklich Ressourcen bekommt, um da mehr zu dem Thema machen zu können. Es ist aber auch gleichzeitig kompliziert, wenn sich das alles an einer Person oder sozusagen die Gruppe, die um Hajo Seppett existiert, und Grit Hartmann auch teilweise mal mitrecherchiert, aber dass sich das dann sozusagen zu sehr konzentriert auf diese eine Gruppe, weil dann könnte so eine Art Feigenblatt-Funktion angetreten werden, dass man immer wieder abschiebt, wir haben doch da die Truppe, die es macht, und die kann natürlich auch nicht alles machen. Also auch da sind die Ressourcen weiterhin beschränkt. Und man kann jetzt nicht einfach immer nur darauf warten, dass alle paar Monate mal ein neuer 20-Minuten-Halbstunde kommt, wo dann wieder das Thema bearbeitet wurde. Dann kann man im Jahresbericht oder in einer Pressekonferenz einmal pro Jahr sagen, wir haben das Thema ja ausführlich behandelt in den vier Dokumentationen. Das ist auch nicht ausreichend. Also dafür müssen schon mehr Leute Ressourcen bekommen. Und es muss auch alltäglicher werden. Das ist ja das, was wir gerade schon ausführlich besprochen haben. Dass eben auch ganz normale zwei- dreimalige Mütter zwischendurch entstehen, kleine Einspieler, wo genau das Thema behandelt wird. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die es in der Tour de France total gab. Das ist auch noch nicht alles okay. Aber ich war ja mal drei Jahre sozusagen bei Tour de France vor Ort und durfte das auch mal im ZDF-Produktionsteam miterleben. Das ist viel alltäglicher geworden, auch in den Redaktionsbesprechungen damals. Dass man überlegt, okay, was machen wir jetzt zum Thema Doping? Und dann gibt es einen, der macht genau so was, wie es jetzt bei WM gesagt hat. Der läuft den ganzen Tag, rennt den Fahrer nach Zielanfahrt hinterher. Braucht man vier Konditionen für und beobachtet einfach mal, was passiert, sozusagen von der Züge bis er vom Schaperau eingefangen wurde und zur Kontrolle gebracht worden und so. Das sind ja ganz normale Beiträge, die überall umsetzbar sind. Hab ich jetzt was zu deiner Frage vergessen?
Ich glaube, du hast schon die Frage, wie wichtig dann so eine Figur oder ein Narrativ, wie du es dann etabliert hast, ist, ganz gut in beide Richtungen beantwortet, glaube ich. Also ja, auf der einen Seite natürlich wichtig, aber auf der anderen Seite kann es eben auch als Feigenblatt wirten. Und der Komplex ist zu groß, eigentlich nur für ein Team aus Journalisten. Deswegen darf man sich nicht nur auf deren Arbeit verlassen und auch nicht nur deren Arbeit als Hinweis darauf nehmen, dass man sich mit Doping auseinandergesetzt hat.
Ich weise kurz darauf hin, dass es bei der ARD natürlich auch die Sendung WDR Sport in Tarpf gibt, die sehr verdienstvoll ist. Und dort gibt es nicht nur – das ist ein bisschen weiterer verandert – aber schon auch Beiträge, die sich mit Doping befassen und die nicht von H. Seppelt sind.
Aber weißt du, was mich da eilgert, Grit, bei dieser Sendung? Das ist meiner Meinung nach die beste sport-journalistische TV-Sendung, die es in Deutschland gibt. Und die kommt irgendwann unmoderiert, nicht mal mehr inzwischen von einem Moderator moderiert, am Sonntagabend. Und wenn ich dem entgegenhalte, was in der Sportschau um 18.30 im Filetstück der deutschen Sportberichterstattung gemacht wird, da ist das nur, wir gucken jetzt, ach, die Partie Hamburg gegen den 1. FC Kaiserslautern, die gab es ja schon mal 1984. Und damals ist eine Eckfahne umgefallen. Wir fragen nochmal alle Beteiligten dazu. Das ist das, was mich wirklich manchmal ärgert. Man muss ja auch nicht mit kritischer Berichterstattung den Leuten die Freude am Sport nehmen. Aber warum finden so tolle journalistische Inhalte in einer so versteckten Nische statt und werden ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz selten mal ins breitere Lampenlicht, Rampenlicht getrieben?
Also das ist natürlich eine Frage, die völlig berechtigt ist, die ich jetzt noch nicht beantworten kann. Aber das kleine Trostpflaster ist sozusagen, dass sie unmoderiert ist, finde ich übrigens gut. Ich brauche keinen Moderator. Wenn ich drei gute Beiträge mit jeweils einem Vorspann hintereinander bekomme, muss ich nicht einen haben, der dazwischen vor dem Puls steht und mir noch was erzählt. Das glaube ich nicht. Aber zumindest gibt es die Tendenz, dass es immer mehr Beiträge von Sport Inside gibt, wenn sie gut sind, wenn sie investigativ sind. Das ist dort die überwiegende Zahl der Beiträge, dass es Kurzfassungen davon zumindest in der Sportschau gibt. Das ist schon so am selben Wochenende. Das sind dann nicht zehn Minuten wie bei Sport Inside, sondern fünf Minuten.
Es ist auch nicht die 1830-Sportur. Ich weiß, dass jede Sendeminute sehr eng verplant ist, aber das ist das, wo alle hingucken.
Ja, doch ab und an gibt es das da. Ab und an auch da. Es könnte häufiger sein. Aber ich glaube, das ist eine gute Entwicklung. Und ansonsten ist das natürlich richtig mit der Nische. Da kann ich nichts anderes sagen.
Sorry, Grit, natürlich. Ich muss auch noch unterstützen. Das ist der Arsch auf mein Haupt. Das ist das einzige Format, das wöchentlich kritische Sportberichterstattung bringt. In einem regelmäßigen Format. Also klar, hätte ich natürlich benennen müssen. Wir wollen jetzt hier nicht mit so kleinen Medienkritik anfangen, aber mein Problem als Nutzer, der wenig in den Jahresfernsehen noch schaut, ist bei SportInside, die PR-Arbeit, um den eigenen Beitrag zu kriegen. Bei mir ploppt das kaum noch auf, außer ich werde daran erinnert. Ich weiß, ich hatte eine Kollegin Beitrag gemacht, den will ich unbedingt noch sehen. Und bei Twitter mal, wenn das vermarktet wird. Aber ich muss mich erst mal um Bemühen oder erinnert werden. Ach ja, stimmt, wieder SportInside-Sendung. Was ist denn da passiert? Jetzt kriege ich mich mal durch die Mediathek. Das ist ein bisschen mein Problem. SportInside-Sendung habe ich mich gerade auch vergessen.
Dazu kommt, du hast auch unregelmäßige Sendetermine. Es gibt eine sehr lange Sommerpause, wenn keine Bundesliga ist. Das macht es nicht ganz so einfach. Aber die Frage war ja, eigentlich reicht das, wenn man so eine Liedfigur hat wie Hajo bei der Doping-Berichterstattung. Wie gesagt, Fernsehen ist nicht alles. Es gibt auch ein paar andere, die nicht fürs Fernsehen arbeiten, die wir auch nicht vergessen wollen, die sich um Doping bemühen. Aber ich finde, so eine Liedfigur wie Hajo kann nur gut sein, wenn sie dazu motiviert, dass sich auch andere Kollegen häufiger mit dem Thema befassen. Ich denke, dass das der Weg sein muss. Denn Hajo kann natürlich nicht alles machen. So ein Lieblingsvorwurf von Leuten, die man nicht unbedingt ernst nehmen muss – ich sage Ihnen trotzdem mal, der war, der kümmert sich ja immer nur um Russland. Wieso kümmert er sich denn jetzt nicht um Frum? Wer aber die Abläufe kennt, der weiß selbstverständlich, dass wenn du gerade einen halben Stunden Film machst zum Fußball in Brasilien und einem Doping-Arzt dockt, das ist das, was gerade gelaufen ist, dann hast du überhaupt keine große Zeit, dich noch um einen anderen wichtigen Fall zu kümmern. Und das ist nun wieder ein Indiz dafür, dass es auch nicht gut ist, es nur an einem aufzuhängen. Ja, also das ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert, aber ich denke, das hajo schon. Und ich weiß es auch, bei seiner Firma gibt es also eine Menge neue junge Kollegen, die viele außerhalb noch gar nicht kennen, die aber bei ihm arbeiten, sehr glücklich darüber sind, dass sie das können und sozusagen hoffnungsvolle junge und kluge Kollegen sind, die da auch auf eine Schiene gebracht werden. Und das ist ganz schön, glaube ich.
Absolut. Ja, das ist eine richtige Tendenz. Wir wollen langsam zum Schluss dieser Sendung kommen. Ich habe auch schon eure Zeit etwas länger beansprucht als eigentlich vereinbart. Deswegen nur noch eine abschließende Frage an euch beide. Jonathan, du darfst mal anfangen. Ihr als Doping-Experten, glaubst du, bei dieser WM sind von den 736 Spielern gedopte Spieler mit dabei? Zu wie viel Prozent bist du davon überzeugt?
Ich bin davon überzeugt, dass Spieler bei dieser WM gedopt sind. Das traue ich mich zu sagen. Ich habe vorhin schon einmal beantwortet, wie viele das sind, in welcher Nation. Da kann ich nicht zu sagen. Da kann ich nur den Hinweisen folgen und irgendwann vielleicht kann man mal was darüber sprechen.
Genau. Bei dir ist die Überzeugung als jemand, der sich wirklich viel mit der Materie beschäftigt. Du bist dir sicher, es sind gedopte Spieler mit bei diesen Fußball-Chinien dabei?
Ich bin mir sicher bei dieser WM und ich bin auch sicher, dass in der Bundesliga gedopte Spieler dabei sind. Also bin ich mir eigentlich bei jedem großen, im professionellen Fußball sozusagen, bei jeder großen Liga und jedem großen Turnierformat sicher.
Grit, deckt sich das mit deiner Einschätzung?
Ja, also ich würde mal die Mindestwerte der Studien, die da so gemacht wurden, sind auch von der UEFA selbst im Übrigen. Das lag dann mal bei acht Prozent mit Testosteronen, Spitzenfußballer, die Umfrage in der Bundesliga bis zu 25 Prozent, in der Spanischen Liga bis zu 30 Prozent. Also ich bin ein bisschen kühner und sage, dass aber mindestens ein Drittel der Spieler, die bei dieser WM antreten – und eigentlich würde ich sogar noch höher gehen – dass die in dieser Saison mit Doping-Mitteln umgegangen sind und gedruckt haben.
Schade, dass es nicht wie bei einem Tippspiel ist.
Wir können es leider nicht, aber wirklich.
Das wäre ein etwas makaberes Tippspiel.
Spanische Liga – Umfrage. 30 Prozent geben es zu vor zwei Jahren. In Deutschland geben es 25 Prozent zu. Du hast, wenn du mit Leuten sprichst, die solche Umfragen machen, hast du immer noch einen 50-Prozent-Satz, die es nicht zugeben. Das sind Mindestwerte. Das sind Mindestwerte. Das sind nicht nur die Topspieler. Ich glaube, dass im Fußball die Duping-Prävalenz extrem hoch ist. Der Fußball schützt sich auch durch die Kontrollen, die noch sehr viele Alibi-Hafter sind, als sie in anderen Sportarten sind. Er will nicht finden, er schützt sich. Warum soll das geringer sein als in anderen Sportarten? Es ist eher höher.
Das setzt aber auch auf jeden Fall fest. Dieses Thema wird noch häufiger im Rasenfunk stattfinden. Vielleicht auch noch mal, wenn ich darf, mit euch in dieser Runde. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit. Zum einen Grit Hartmann bei Twitter. Grit, vielen Dank, dass du dein Debüt im Rasenfunk gegeben hast und dir so viel Zeit genommen hast für diese Sendung. Und außerdem ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an dich, Jonathan Sachse, at J. Sachse bei Twitter. Folgt auch at Fußball Doping. Und ihr könnt euch auch mal das Correctiv angucken, wo Jonathan inzwischen arbeitet. Jonathan, es war wie immer eine große Freude mit dir zu sprechen, obwohl das Thema ein nicht ganz so leicht verdauerliches an manchen Stellen ist. Danke dir.
Danke auch an euch.
Und auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war ein Tribünengespräch. Es wird noch ein weiteres Tribünengespräch geben, auch zu einem nicht ganz so einfachen Thema. Sagen wir mal, es wird um die FIFA gehen. Mal gucken, wann das veröffentlicht wird, vermutlich noch im Verlaufe dieser WM. Ansonsten gibt es die täglichen WM-Kurzpässe. Und ich freue mich, wenn ihr uns unterstützt, auf rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück um die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.